you know the whole and it's not you it's
it's it's most women today that I end up
talking to and if you go back to the
other ladies night's panel like you'll
see a few of these gals too it's like
they're drunk on the Kool-Aid of toxic
feminism I don't know if you know what
toxic feminism is what is toxic feminism
would you describe yourself as a
feminist like do you think that you're
into that sort of stuff um I don't like
to go based off of labels um I would
describe myself as someone who supports
um men just as much as I support women
okay do you like when you hear um I
don't know would be a good
example um like how does the word word
patriarchy uh sit with
you do you think we live in a patriarchy
or do we live in a
matriarchy
um I think we live in an Archy I don't
know like um there's different areas for
different things I think you can see a
little bit of both depending on
what do you see
clearly
um it really depends on the field um in
healthcare it's very women dominated
um I think in general uh for businesses
you're going to see more patriarchy with
sales um more likely to be CEOs of
companies and in exact
positions um when it comes to
finances
um I think that the nuclear family is
built on the patriarch
idea because because I mean the the
thing that's in the blind spots of a lot
of GS your age and mostly a little bit
older like it's usually about by about
34 35 36 or so it's like there's a
painted picture of this guy that they
want and that same guy that you want is
looking at girl Aubrey's
age 19 20 21 22 23 24 like it's easy for
them to date those girls because they
got their [__] together they have money
they're captivating they can invite
girls like Aubrey into their life and be
like hey you know we're going on on the
boat this weekend you want to bring a
few friends and come they're going to
invite her and her friends before they
invite you and your friends right and
that's not to
like disparage anybody that's just to
get to the reality of what drives
attraction between the sexes
because men and women Peak at different
parts in their life right like do you
understand the differences between the
sexual market value Peak between men and
women or is it the same in your mind is
there like a big difference between you
and your girlfriend in age or I don't
get into those details like I don't tell
people my age but I say seven to 15
years okay yeah she's younger than me by
seven to 15 years yeah um now um most
men are looking for someone who's under
30 yeah I mean like for me if I was was
single I probably wouldn't even date in
40 i' I'd probably date 40 and under
you're probably 20 to 40 and
realistically probably younger than 40
be honest with you but um that's that's
the differences you know between men and
women like where do you think women peak
in their um sexual Marketplace value as
far as their attraction and value to men
like where do you see that Peak for you
or does it just follow you sort of as
you go through
life I mean I
think that there is ATT traction with
age as well um I've always been someone
to date older so but I mean women
typically do date older they usually
date older guys Aubrey's with an older
guy Jessica is your husband older or
younger older Gia is your husband older
or younger older older right so most
women typically date older than their
own ages again usually s to 10 years is
within range for women 5 to 10 years
some wom will say three to five years
right but it's generally always older
right mhm so there's that but I mean
like where do you think women Peak or is
there a peak for
women I
mean I think I'm only continuing to peek
but
that's I don't think that there's really
a time when women age out that's just
me okay do do you think there's a time
when men age
out I got called Old last week by one of
the I think when you're seeing someone
who's the same age as you or around your
same age that's what I mean by like
there's
not really a time when you're not going
to view someone the same age as you as
having past their Peak I guess that yeah
so toxic feminism is like that Kool-Aid
that women are drunk on which like you
know gets into climb the corporate
ladder get a you know get a career a
woman needs a man like a fish needs a
bicycle men and women are equal I mean I
mean you know if men and women are equal
then why did this uh Lydia or Linda
whatever her name was that was a man you
know 462 and the professional swimming
Championship with men suck so badly and
then decide to compete with women and
came in first place and took all of
their medals right you've probably heard
about this dude you know in the news so
you know men men and women are very very
different and I think that one of the
great lies that toxic feminism tells
women is that men and women are the same
uh you know
wh it's funny because it tells women
that we're both the same but then it
also sells like some sort of victim
mindset to women like a lot of women
will be like well you know if the
patriarchy wouldn't be oppressing women
and paying them 78 cents and a dollar
for every dollar that a man makes blah
blah blah like those are some of the
those are some of the lines right and I
don't think that you're that you're
drunk on that Kool-Aid but I think
there's certain elements of it like well
tattoos are like a masculine Pursuit
like a masculine trait and they always
have been for a very long time and it's
only in recent history now that women
start getting tattoos right and it's
like that's kind of a masculine you know
Pursuit but now we have women doing it
sort of thing so there's a few of those
things that I see elements and it's like
you can't do anything about it right I
remember we had this gon once I think
she was in her 50s and she was tattooed
from like head to toe and I asked her I
said you know do you do you regret any
of this and she's like yeah it was
stupid it was it was a really bad mood
and I've been disqualified by a lot of
men because my
tattoos I haven't had that so you'll get
it if you keep
going okay but I mean there's there's
there's lots of guys out there that will
look past stuff like that today so right
but but they're generally not the kind
of guys that you want to be in a
long-term relationship with and travel
with and stuff like that again the guy
that you're describing like that like
that perfect guy for you I talk to this
guy a lot he's very successful he's got
his [__] together and he's looking past
a lot of the
uh qualities that you carry with you
that he wouldn't be interested you know
for example like you know if he wants to
have kids he's going to pass on you
he'll lay with you you know he'll sleep
with you but he's gonna move on like
once he
does a lot of guys in this space really
quick like a lot of guys in your space
obsess over this like age 30 kind of
thing and so I mean the problem is that
what's not being sold to a lot of women
is that an ounce of prevention is better
than a pound of cure yeah you know women
don't just turn 30 and become they talk
about there's this concept of the wall
people think oh you smash into the wall
and you become ugly that's not what that
means it essentially means are you
getting the same amount of attention at
some for some people the wall is 27 for
some people it's 37 generally speaking
though it's around you know early 30s
but it's are you getting the same amount
of attention from men or are you getting
the attention from the quality of men in
your maybe early 30s and you were in
your early 20s and
on balanced probabilities most likely
the answer to that is going to be no but
it's not because women just overnight
turn in to go from carriages to pumpkins
it's because many of them are being told
to spend their 20s smoking drinking
doing drugs partying letting dozens if
not hundreds of guys run through them
and then that eventually catches up to
them to a point where well now they're
really starting to feel those effects
it's like hangovers like when you're 21
too like you can go and slam two dozen
drinks down and then the next morning
wake up and and do it again and you know
a couple years later you have two or
three drinks and you're on the couch for
the next 24 48 hours in some cases and
so that's sort of where
that feminist sort of brainwashing comes
into play where it's telling women to
chase all of these fruitless Pursuits
thinking that it's not going to affect
them later in life they're not going to
wake up 10 years later and hate
themselves for the decisions that they
made and cenace you may or may not
experience this you know you may
experience having regrets in a few years
you may not I mean everybody's different
in
situations um but it's it's one of those
things where you can't go back in the
story and so it's always better to sort
of and and that's the conversations we
have with women and the conversations we
have with men where it says you know men
are only kicking ass in their 30s and
40s if they do the work in the 20s to
set themselves up to get there you don't
just magically become this successful
guy the day you turned 35 like a lot of
people would have you think just like
you don't just magically turn into a
pumpkin as a woman the day you turn 30
your 20s matter and the decisions you
make matter and I think that's a
conversation a lot of people are not
having there's this this we're in the
age of inconsequential ISM where no
matter what you do you're always going
to be okay and always be taken care of
and a lot of people are waking up at
those ages and they're pissed so I think
that's kind of the conversations we're
trying to have not hey you're 30 and you
[__] your life up sorry for your luck
it's is hey you know you may have been
told some things that may or may not
have been your fault there's time to
turn those things around and whether you
do or whether you don't it's fully up to
you but here are some things that maybe
you go away from this conversation
considering if you do find yourself
struggling to kind of find that thing or
find that guy that you're ultimately
looking for I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out